hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcasting
just checking in
just checking it on you
yes hey how are you
how's it going oh did I want to [__]
turn my car into a weapon today
and just [__] rim into somebody I
gotta get one of those old school like
[__] cop like push bars
you know those there's two cut types of
[__] well there's a lot of [__]
but with the two types of [__] that
were driving me nuts I was in traffic
and I had to pick my daughter up from
school and uh you know I don't like
being late
so of course you know that person that
like when traffic starts happening they
put their hazard lights on
and then they do like 40 car lengths
behind the person I had that person I
got out of that lane you know and I'm
like all right you know that person is
actually
you know the most civilized out of
everybody out here
okay and I'm just reacting to this
person simply because
I am panicking that I'm going to be late
to pick up my daughter and she'll no
longer love me and everyone will leave
I'm just catastrophizing in my head so
he's not really a [__] I'm really the
I'm impatient I'm [__] impatient all
right put the hazard lights really
we get it Europe what do you get what do
you you got your insurance companies has
you on video you [__]
[__]
all right I'm trying to be you know the
bigger man here and then I get behind
this douche in a [__] red Mercedes
and um he's doing that thing where he
now he's 10 car links behind because but
it's because he's staring at his [__]
phone
he's staring at his [__] he literally
has it like up in front of his face
you know what I mean he's not even doing
like you know the glancing down like
you're counting cards or whatever the
[__] these cheats do and get my they get
their their their hands smashed by the
guys at casino right this guy is like
he has it held up in front of his face
like he's taken a selfie and he's
letting car after car and so finally I
beep at him what does he do he puts his
window down and he's got his hand like
oh what the [__] yeah we're like we're
in traffic like what is your [__]
problem
so I mind you staring at your phone so
now he's you know what does he do he
goes into extra he goes into on purpose
[__] mode
on purpose cut mode he starts [__]
you know just slowing down I'm like oh I
see what you want you want me to lose my
[__] I will not do that sir
I will not give you the satisfaction I
will let it stay in me
for the rest of the day until I do my
podcast and then I'll [__] let it out
when you don't see it sorry this is all
just petty [__]
you know like the the level of people
looking at their [__] cell phones
um
and I judge all of them even though I do
it too
you know I'm more like trying to find a
song
these people like look like they're I
don't know what they're doing face
timing with loved ones they haven't seen
in years it's like really intense oh so
basically what you say in bill is when
other people do it it's [__] up but
you're doing it because you love music
yeah that's what I'm doing I'm
justifying my [__] Behavior
um
anyway the music I've been listening to
lately because I went uh I switched up
my drum kit
where I had like a small floor time of
14 and then I just have like a 12 rack
and uh oh my God the the the the toms
they're singing right now I tuned them
up the other day uh nice
like just found that sweet spot and they
just [__]
it's just perfect
and just hearing things and it's
creating patterns and all that I'm kind
of getting lost in it and it's been
amazing
and uh I started listening to
um
I was playing this thing for my kids
there's this album that uh
Stan Getz made with Bill Evans on piano
and it has you know a lot of like
mid-level sort of jazz [__]
uh that I can kind of play along to and
I was like that went pretty good then I
put on that Miles Davis cooking with
Miles remember that year like he put out
like Five albums
cooking with Miles hanging with Miles
chilling with miles miles with Miles
like I don't know if he was just like
[__] this record label how many albums
do I owe you
four fantastic and they just turned on
the uh the recording because I don't
find any of them particularly I mean
with my ears I don't find any of them
anywhere near as good as
I feel the [__] that he did with Tony
Williams right through jack diesel net
in the 60s like for me that is the
period of Miles Davis
that I want to listen to that I will
never get sick of
I love all of that [__]
um
like miles Smiles I love that album in a
silent way I love that album uh you know
[__] is Brew if I'm in some [__] up
mood just putting that on
and just listening to that [__] I just I
love
Sketches of Spain I just love all of
that stuff
I could I could listen to that forever
that four and More album I always talk
about I could just listen to that stuff
forever and however but people were
telling me Oh you want to learn how to
play like jazz drum get there's like
those four albums that miles did
um
just play along to that [__] keeping
time and stuff and then stuff will start
to make sense and kind of what I like
about Jeff Bill what do you like about
jazz drumming I like it because I don't
listen to the drummer where I listen to
the band where like in rock music I'm
kind of listening to the drummer to see
what the [__] he's doing
and then because it's a repeated pattern
or a fill or something like that where
like jazz it's just kind of the guy's
you know
I don't have enough years left in my
life to try and memorize every goddamn
thing the person does so it's just like
well [__] this guy I'll just listen to
them I just said [__] this guy to Philly
Joe Jones I'm gonna listen to the band
and I was having a good goddamn time
all right just an old bald ginger in his
garage
um having a good time but uh anyway I'm
just babbling here speaking of having a
good time your [__] Florida
Panthers
just swept the Carolina Hurricanes and
everybody was saying was going to stop
whoever the [__] ran into him after the
Brewing [__] the bed but did the Bruins
really [__] the bed now
okay
we beat him three [__] times that's
more than the Maple Leafs and the
Hurricanes can say combined
the Panthers lost three games in the
first round one in the second round zero
in the third round the Eastern
Conference Finals and I'll tell you I've
watched more [__] Panthers games in
the last month than I've watched in the
history of that [__] franchise
and
tonight's game I was already convinced
that these guys are just gonna [__]
win the cup they're just gonna win the
cup that's it that's just all it is
it's all it is just watching that
[__] game tonight
that Sergey
bobrowsk Broski whatever his [__]
name is I mean gee even if he misses it
these [__] still hit the post the
crossbar I mean this guy is blessed I
gotta say these guys name now that
goodest guy has been killing everybody
Anthony duclair both Sams Reinhardt and
Bennett and of course the engine Matthew
could chuck I mean they're just [__]
Relentless and I don't understand I said
that they were gonna face what they
haven't faced in the first two rounds of
the playoffs they were going to face
defense and I gotta be honest with you
they didn't I don't know what the [__]
people are doing standing around this
little poke check [__] [__] that
didn't work with the Bruins didn't work
with the Maple Leafs
didn't work through the first three
[__] games of the goddamn series and
they're still doing it
occasionally I saw one time a guy lined
somebody up on on uh the Hurricanes line
somebody up on Florida
for a big hit the guy actually avoided
it on the Panthers but he completely
disrupted them going into the Zone they
turned the puck over and I'm sitting
there watching the game going yeah more
of that
more of that this [__] backing into
your Zone and trying to poke the puck
away is not [__] working and people
continue to do it but I'll tell you they
had a goal tonight
what was it they they
stole it half wall and it was one two
three four [__] passes like I was
watching the goddamn Globetrotters it's
in the back of the net the [__]
hurricanes show up the game is tied they
tie it late three to three it's going
into overtime
all right I'm brushing out my daughter's
hair and she's going Dad Dad as she says
when is this over
I'm like well they just I don't know and
then they the [__] they put the
Panthers on the power play and I'm like
well it's now it's going to end in the
next 50 seconds because these [__]
guys
are Relentless and and and within
regulation they came in they beat him to
win the Eastern Conference Final
and now they're off
to just claim what is rightfully theirs
I am 100 sold on them I don't know much
about the Vegas Knights or uh uh uh who
the [__] are they playing
whoever beat the Kraken the Dallas Stars
I don't give a [__] about either one of
those teams
if they're gonna show up
through the Stanley Cup Final and they
are not going to get physical with these
guys it's just it's [__] over
um
I'll be honest with you I'm really
confused
as to uh uh what constitutes playoff
hockey now
um there's the is an astounding lack of
physical contact
um just throughout the playoffs it's
just I mean it's good because I guess
these guys aren't going to get like the
um all that that
whatever the [__] they call that [__]
it's encephalitis
they call that [__]
the stuff that [__] with your brain
they're not going to get it so that's a
good thing but it's just you know
um
it's just I don't know it's it's a
different game so what are you gonna do
anyway congratulations to them
they're just
they're actually like I can't even
explain they're just they're fun to
[__] watch I'm sitting there going I
am they'll forever be an expansive
franchise to me all right they just are
always going to be that and these
[__] are gonna win this Stanley
Cup and
I don't know
if enough people in Miami are even gonna
realize it
you know
there's just going to be a lot of shock
people walking around with board shorts
and bikinis going what is that duck boat
doing driving down the foot the [__]
street with all those toothless lunatics
um
I don't know I shouldn't say all this
nice [__] about them I'm gonna [__]
Jinx him but I don't give a [__] what do
I care I think they're gonna like
I think they're gonna they're they're
gonna Breeze through the next round
um if people are going to continue to
[__] just sort of back into your Zone
and try to poke check the puck away
I I don't know I I don't understand why
three rounds in a row watching that not
work they just continued to do it
um
but I I you know
I don't know I I I I I feel like I'm
taking something away from Florida by
saying this [__] like this but I just
I'm I'm confused
like how many times do you want to
[__] lose to this team like what
you're doing is not working
um anyway
oh God the Bruins just got physical with
them we could have beat him in [__]
five games six games
we had two of the final three games one
and then we went oh I guess we got that
dilemma they just [__] skated by us
and score to go hey what happened
what happened is this
all right that's
where as I can be okay
you don't [__] put this goddamn thing
on
you know to listen to intelligence or or
or or or or whatever
um I want to thank everybody that said
um
that they enjoyed the Paul
uh Paul Anka interview that I did I want
to thank uh Chef Josiah and his team at
dear Jane's for letting us use the um
um the restaurant and everything to
shoot in there people really I've got so
many nice compliments from you guys I
really appreciate it I'm glad you
enjoyed it and
um what a thrill to meet a show business
Legend like that
um
all right and what else oh I'm getting
my old my my new truck I'm finally
getting the clear wrap put on it and a
little bit of tint I'm very excited I
miss my truck already and then my old
truck I'm getting some electrical work
done on it so uh I think that's kind of
the final thing I have to do I have an
aftermarket AC in there that anytime I
gotta like turn like the heat on hot
which means the AC is on like just that
dumb [__] I'm sick of [__] dealing
with that and then I when I turn it on I
don't know what's going on but like all
of this dandruff comes flying out into
my [__] face and I'm like all right I
guess we're shutting this off now
so I got to get all of that taken care
of you know if it's not if it's not one
thing it's another
you know
um
so anyway let me see is there any reads
here for this week
is there any reads
all right let's do some reads here where
did they go what happens oh it's simply
safe you know everyone spring is In
Bloom and you know what comes next
vacation season if you got the money
he didn't blow it all on Weed Man uh but
before you pack your bags be sure to
secure your home with Simply Safe home
security with simply safe enjoy greater
Peace of Mind knowing your home is
monitored Around the Clock by trained
agents ready to act to defend against
break-ins fires and other threats and
control from anywhere anytime with the
top rated Simply Safe app stay connected
from anywhere anytime armor disarm your
system remotely check your cameras to
make sure everything's okay you can even
unlock the front door to let a guest in
easy to set up or choose Professional
installation simply say ships to your
door and it's easy to set up yourself in
just about 30 minutes or have simply
saved certified technicians install it
for you that's what I would do no reason
to wait with financing through a firm
secure your home today and pay overtime
and pay overtime in installments that
fit your budget
uh customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com go today and claim your
free indoor security system plus 20 off
your order with interactive monitoring
that's simplysafe.com
there's no safe
like simply safe
okay and lastly but certainly certainly
not leastly it's all zip
recruit everybody
um if you were to start a new business
what would it be
whether you're starting a new business
or growing one if you want to be
successful
if you want to have your foot on the
neck of your competition you need the
most talented people on your team that's
where it zipped it comes in and right
now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
why should you let zip
yeah help you hire for your business
that's because it's powerful matching
technology finds highly qualified
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles got your eye on one or two people
who'd be perfect for your job let me do
that again got your eye on two people
but not in a perverted way but in a
business way who'd be perfect for your
job zip
let you send them a personal invite
so they're more likely to apply zip
uh also offers attention grabbing labels
that speak to job flexibility like
remote training provided urgent and more
to really help you out let zip recruiter
fill all your roles with the light look
the right candidates four to five
employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free that's
ziprecruited.com
again that zip
[Applause]
[Music]
that was me screaming out of a Porsche
driving by uh.com slash Burr spell
outbur
b-u-r-r-z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
all right who's next here who's next
um oh look who it is oh goodness
gracious it's butcher box
all right be ready for dinner no one
likes to rush to the market at the last
minute for something to make when your
day is done reward yourself with a
freezer full of quality food with
butcher butcherbox butcherbox with
butcher box you can easily find high
quality Meat and seafood you can trust
it's a hundred percent grass-fed beef
free range organic chicken pork raise
crate food and wild caught Seafood you
don't know what they're gonna do
humanely raised before they're murdered
no antibiotics are headed hormones
it gets delivered right to your doorstep
with free shipping always and customized
uh box plans which Box gives you a
variety of high quality cuts at an
amazing value with exclusive member
deals uh recipe
inspirate guides tips and hacks butcher
boxes giving us a special deal sign up
today with your code bird to receive
ground beef for a year plus twenty
dollars off your first order
um that's two pounds of ground beef free
in every box for a year plus two dollars
four [__] Burgers giant ones that's
like eight Quarter Pounders uh twenty
dollars off your first order when you
sign up at butcherbox.com
that's butcherbox.com use the code bird
you're gonna eat two burgers a week for
free for a year come on you're all over
that
all right wait there's one more don't
shame when people go wait I lied it's
like he didn't lie you [__] up
why would I lie about this I thought
there was only three I [__] up I
didn't scroll down far enough I did not
lie Helix everybody Helix it's Helix
sleep the Helix lineup offers 20 unique
mattresses including the award-winning
Luxe collection with the newly released
Helix Elite collections of mattress
designed for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress made just for kids oh so
how will you know which Helix mattress
works best for you and your body well
you take the Helix sleep quiz and find
out your perfect find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes
under two minutes like the feds are
kicking in the door and your
personalized mattresses shipped straight
to your door free of charge
um Helix knows there's no better way to
try out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own home that's why they
offer a 100 night
trial
gross and a 10 to 15 year warranty to
try out your new Helix mattress try it
out man anything you're going to do on
this mattress in the next hundred nights
we want you to do it to make sure you
got the right one I don't want to take
my word for it Helix has been awarded
the number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine it's even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep uh
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and even two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now
all right once again maybe I have I
don't know I I my internet sucks
the [__] internet I mean
oh good I need to have somebody Young
look at what I pay a month
on on uh whatever that Dish Network [__]
is and what I pay for cable and I know
that they I probably pay 300 a month
laughs
I know there's a better way to do this I
know there's apps
and and and and and things
you know I put it on my computer and
then I beam it to the T I know there's a
better way to do this
um
oh man I was gonna have red band do that
before he moved to [__] Austin Texas
he was like dude I'll come over to your
house uh he goes I did it to my with you
know his mother or something was paying
like an extra 200 a month that she
didn't need to be paying and he got on
the phone and got the whole [__]
thing knocked down and um
I don't know I have to be on some board
at DirecTV
where they're just saying like I have to
be like a five-star client
Under The Heading he still hasn't
figured it out
he doesn't understand there's a cheaper
way to get the exact same package and we
will never tell him and it's going to be
a picture of me and like five retirees
in Sarasota Florida that all that you
know as far as like paying for cable a
month or whatever the [__] I'm paying
for satellite feed I have to be in the
top five
uh in in Los Angeles I would say I think
everybody knows a better way to do it
than me but what are you going to do
um speaking of that
I watched
um
Glenn Gary Glenn Ross with some friends
of mine the other night I had you know I
saw that in the movie theater and I had
yet to uh
I don't know I always loved the movie I
just never went back and watched it so
we were like yeah let's [__] watch
that movie dude Jack Lemmon in that
movie
I love how his character like always
like blows up and then immediately dials
it back you know he'll be like he'd be
like you [__] come on just give me
the good leads
It's [__] amazing
and the scene where the guy that Al
Pacino's character he talks him in
to write in the check and then he's got
to come back because his wife says don't
cash the check and watching
Pacino spin them around the room again
it's just like uh
it's just gut wrenching it's such a
gut-wrenching scene to watch because all
I see is the younger me I was one of the
most gullible [__] you wanna hear a
[__] story
is that what you want I got one for you
I told this a long time ago
I came down to New York City
all right
in
1994.
okay just totally grown up growing up in
the suburbs I didn't know [__] I took a
train
to the Port Authority
I got out of the train I'm walking up
and this dude goes yo man you want a cab
you want a cab and I was like yes and he
goes follow me so I start following them
and we're going down like this dark
thing and everything in me is going like
don't follow him down there
but I was old Billy Nice Guy full head
of orange hair I'm like well I don't
want to
Whip and I followed the guy thank God he
didn't [__] kill me he hailed a cab
and then he said I owed him money and
I'm going to tip him oh I told this
story before it was a long time ago
though and I had this Asian cab driver
he was trying to help me he's going no
no no no no pay you pay me no pay here
and the guy was jumping up down took a
20 and ran away
and I got in the cab and I was
immediately was embarrassed and he goes
you don't pay him you pay me he just
kept going where you from where you from
I was just going like oh my God just
wherever the [__] I was going
I think at that point I was crashing at
some other Comics because I was trying
to get like
stage time or whatever he just kept
going where you from
where you from I was like Massachusetts
and and like he just gave me the lay of
the land
he goes let me tell you something he
goes
he goes somebody come up to you you tell
him get the [__] away
they still come up to you you say Lotto
get the [__] away
where you from
the whole cab ride it was [__]
embarrassing but I also appreciated the
guy actually gave a [__] about me
and then I was just like all right
I uh people can see that I am a sucker
from a mile away so I immediately went
to like one of those Army Navy Surplus
stores and just bought a bunch of [__]
that made it look like uh you know I was
a way bigger problem than I was and then
I was not looking at anybody but just
was really paying attention to how to
carry yourself on the subway this is
when you know all this [__] that you
hear and now that's going on in New York
starting to come back this was
after the crack 80s right as Giuliani
was coming in and you know
stuff happened
on the subway that uh you know a lot of
you know you know what it was a lot of
exposure
a lot of [__] in public a lot of
male junk homeless male junk is you know
just a lot of [__] like that I I saw I
never really saw um saw a couple of
fights nothing [__] crazy so
um anyway so I started dressing I had a
green army coat I went Travis Bickle I
[__] had a green army coat and I had
this black hat that I was wearing
I remember walking into the cellar and
this guy on stage this comic on stage
going Jesus Christ sir you look like
you're ready to rob a [__] bank
and I was embarrassed but I was also
like well it's better than what I did I
I [__] looked like the other way
because I was getting LED down these
dark alleys
like a jackass
um
so anyway that was me
a long time ago and then I became like a
really angry person I think I already
was angry I just didn't realize it and
then and somewhere along the line I kind
of came
kind of came out of that
after uh you know
that's why I hate watching those [__]
shows that my wife always watches it was
a quiet town
you know things like that weren't
supposed to happen here she's always
just forever
watching [__] like that and she tells me
she watches it because she thinks like
what would I do in those situations
to get out of it
and I was and I always go like oh okay
well that's better I thought
that watching a family get murdered was
your way of entertaining yourself before
you went to bed
speaking of entertaining yourselves
people
I got something for your asses
um
this is stuff called Not Your Father's
Root Beer that has 10 milligrams of
[__] THC in it
and um
which I feel you know
that's like that's the farthest I'll go
usually I like a five I chill out I
giggle a little bit I mean you know I'm
man enough to say that I can giggle
you know
you poke me in my stomach like the
Pillsbury Doughboy you know I might let
my lead out a chuckle not gonna lie to
you might let out a chuckle and every
once in a while you know when I go away
um with my lovely wife to get away for a
couple days like we just did for that
wedding ah yeah you know I'll take a
Tedder and then I'm having a great
[__] time but whatever the fellas
were coming over we're watching a movie
kids were in bed I figured [__] it I'm
gonna drink one of these root beers
and um
I I don't know that I can recommend that
root beer it doesn't taste good
as far as root beers goes it tastes like
there's weed in it it's root beer and it
has wheat in it but if you like those
two things like I do
it's [__] tremendous
and
um
I drank this [__] and I'll be honest
with you I you know I'm thinking all
right I can hand I've eaten a 10 mil
milligram [__]
gummy before I'll tell you this uh
that root beer after a while was telling
me what to say and when to say it
it wasn't a [__] thing I could do
about it there was a little voice to me
saying shut up they're trying
to watch the movie
and I was just doing a bad Al Pacino
going you know
because he's not in that scene when Alec
Baldwin comes in and yells at everybody
you know what I mean
so I was saying all of this [__] I'll
put you know my character would not sit
here
and listen to this [__] talking
to him
in that way at first it was funny and
then nobody was laughing and I just kept
doing it
um later on I remember I was smoking a
pipe
because a bunny of mine started smoking
a pipe so I broke mine out that I got
one long time ago when I was in
Milwaukee and I was just laughing at how
[__]
smart you feel when you smoke a pipe and
you also feel like you're you're back in
time
and my my lovely wife was telling a
story to my other buddy smoking a pipe
and I was sitting there smoking a pipe
and I'm looking at my other buddy looks
at me and I go it's called the cotton
gin
oh
[Music]
that was all [__] I felt like Huck
Finn like I was living back in the day
and Tom Sawyer um I I'm not going to
start smoking a pipe though I will tell
you it's not as harsh as as cigars
I'll say that not as harsh as cigars I
mean is that really a ringing
endorsement though
um
but he had that cherry flavored tobacco
which every time I smell it both my
grandfathers on both sides smoked that
exact same tobacco and it just takes me
back to the 1970s
um hanging out on the front porch we
lived in a a duplex for a Time
um I'll tell you man no no secrets in a
duplex
you know
like if I don't know where your parents
get a divorce the other family's like
yeah yeah we kind of heard that coming
[Laughter]
um you could just [__] hear
everything we lived in this really cool
old house that I loved and like someday
I wanted to buy it back
and um turn it back into a one family
because it was the coolest thing ever to
me it had it was like a uh
you know
I don't know made in like 1900 or like
the 1890s
probably had all lead paint and all of
that [__] in there
um one of those old school [__] rock
foundations you know
um but the coolest thing I thought was
it had it had three staircases
it had like the main staircase the front
of the house where we lived and then it
had a twisty one in the back which back
in the day that was like for the for
like your your maid service
like when people had and like you didn't
want to see them
which how [__] awkward is that like
I mean
make my bed I don't want to see you
right so as they would be downstairs
they'd make you breakfast I think and
they would ring a dinner dinner bell
unless they were allowed to be like sir
yo breakfast is ready
right and then you'd come downstairs
and you woolly mammoth [__] slippers
and then they would walk up the back
stairs and then they would they would
make up the beds or whatever so it had
one of those and then
it had a real third floor attic that you
walked up
stairs all the way up
and
um
it had two rooms up there that were like
bedrooms you could stand up in and then
it had like this creepy attic space
and uh
I always wanted to combine like someday
like buy that thing and combine the
whole [__] thing
never happened never happened I got in
this business
um that was one of those stories I
started telling it and I can't even
remember why the [__] I was telling you
that [__]
I was like talking about back in the day
how I like old stuff this this I'll tell
you something else too this whole
[__] disease I have where I like old
things I'm really trying to grow out of
it
because
when [__] breaks down it just becomes a
[__] trying to find it like the
greatest thing I ever did was I sold
that old Ludwig drum kit
you know what I mean and I don't miss it
at all and I got a you know a couple
years ago I bought a brand new Gretch
broadcaster and
I've never any problem I've ever had
with this yeah we got that part no
problem
it's not that oh hello I got a I don't
know eBay
go on uh Craigslist see if you can find
it it's like uh
but I finally fixed my sciatic [__]
playing drums
is I I wasn't sitting right
um
people always got to sit on your sit
bones I was like what the [__] are those
what are your sit bones and I finally
figured out how to do that
Jesus Christ how [__] old am I am I
really telling you guys yeah I I [__]
learned how to do that I just picture
like my sit bones like the Spurs in the
front of like a bass drum anchor I just
gotta [__] put those in there because
my leg starts getting numb and then when
I readjust it it go it gets unnamed
which never happened before
so I'm excited about that
and I'm excited that the Denver Nuggets
swept the [__] LA Lakers and that the
Boston Celtics prevented themselves from
getting swept
so at least I have that
at least I [__] have that
um it is amazing though if you're up
three games to none
how quickly
that can go south like all of a sudden
now like Miami should be a little bit
nervous
right
it's so [__] up you lose one guy you
have three goddamn games all you got to
do is win one more we win one [__]
game
and then all of a sudden it's like holy
[__] they if the Celtics win the next
one
the next game they're looking at tying
up the series like it happens happens
very very quickly
I don't know if you guys have noticed
but count to three doesn't take that
long does it
I um I'm very proud of the Boston
Celtics that they didn't allow
themselves to get swept especially after
what Charles Barkley was saying about
him at halftime and Shaq and they were a
hundred percent right
that was the hardest part they were 100
right they were like they are trying to
win with Talent they are not
they are not playing with anger with
heart with [__] you know refuse to
lose vibes
well I don't know if they were watching
that halftime thing if that inspired him
but uh
they came out and kicked the [__] out of
him so
Jesus Christ at least we didn't get
swept
like the Los Angeles free agent Lakers
oh God I'm so [__] sick of that every
[__] year these stupid Laker fans
just cheering on players from other
teams
you know acting like they don't notice
what their [__] team is doing and
what their team has done to the [__]
League
um I do blame them yes I do and I blame
uh dead David Stern whatever his [__]
name was because he loved the Lakers he
even said it what's what's your dream
final he goes oh the Lakers first the
Lakers
oh behave
um I will go to my grave thinking that
guy fixed games
100 and if they weren't then they would
be called a sports League rather than an
entertainment league in fact all of them
I like how they they allow the wiggle
room
of that you know
how about the Ridiculousness that a
sports fan like me
is now going to sit here
as legalized organized gambling they are
now in bed with those people
and I'm gonna sit here and act like
these games are on the up and up
I mean the entire existence
of these sports leagues the number one
rule is do not gamble do not associate
yourself with people that gamble stay oh
don't even go in and play poker
stay away from those [__] people but
then all of a sudden it became legal and
they cleaned it up like [__] weed
oh
it is [__] insane that they have all
of this [__] for drinking and driving
but like you can drive down the street
on a hundred milligrams of [__] weed
and then what can they do do they have a
test
Oh Billy nark face here
let me see what nobody listens to this
[__] podcast this I just do this for
me hang on a second let me see something
here it is ridiculous that you can be
high out of your [__] mind
and there's like is there anything let
me see let me see let me see let me see
let me see all right here we go is there
a cop test for weed
in California
uh if the officer suspects drug use in a
person who choose who choose a breath
test a blood test may be ordered however
a blood test can only be requested if
the officer believes the following the
driver is under the influence of
marijuana or other types of drugs
yeah but how long does that take to come
back
you gotta we just send it to the lab you
know you might want to recline your seat
buddy you're going to be here for a
minute
um
I guess there isn't
it's kind of [__] amazing
how can police prove impairment in DUI
marijuana cases
there currently is no breath test oh
dude the day that that comes in there's
going to be a bunch of crying I can't
even say hippies
you know hippies still call it grass
sees new people
and he's new goddamn
you know can you believe I'm judging
marijuana marijuana users is I just
talked to you about my [__] root beer
uh many of the legal restrictions
regarding marijuana use and possession
have been relaxed in California and as a
result there's been an increase in the
number of DUI cases involving marijuana
use really under the California vehicle
code section
23152 f as in Frank Victor Charlie
driving on the influence of marijuana
and Other Drugs both legal and illegal
is a criminal offense unlike DUI alcohol
cases which a driver can be convicted of
a DUI if their blood alcohol level is
0.08 or higher there is no similar per
se statute regarding marijuana and Drug
intoxication this means that the police
and Pros what about all these [__]
people on mushrooms like you know
[__] micro dosing
only you guys hate me right now will you
shut the [__] up Bill
um it's interesting
dare I say
a [__] double standard
um
anyway another show I started watching
I started watching a show called The
White House plumbers plumbers
um
if you're a car guy like I am
you gotta watch that one it has all
these amazing uh
you know it takes place in the early 70s
so it has all these incredible 60s and
70s cars in there and uh it's also got
Woody Harrelson and Justin Thoreau so
they [__] absolutely murder it
and uh the tone of the show
is is it's perfect because they're doing
this Sinister stuff but there's all this
comedy in it I finally got a chance I've
been wanting to watch it I finally sat
down and watched the first episode it's
just one of those ones like all right
I'm in I'm watching all of these so
check that out if you can I forget what
I thought for some reason I thought it
was on HBO
hang on a second let me see here and
then I'm gonna mercifully sign a White
House
plumbers
HBO it is HBO
White House plumbers yeah my HBO series
[Music]
um
yeah I saw the uh
I saw the first [__] episode of it
and uh
definitely check it out
um
I just love the names from back then
e Howard hunt G Gordon Liddy that was
like a big thing back then
go and buy your initials
um anyway sorry that is the podcast
congratulations to the [__] Denver
Nuggets I think I'm going to be rooting
for them only because the heat have won
a bunch I mean I I really don't see the
heat losing foreign Celtics I'm hoping
it's gonna happen but uh I will be
rooting for uh the nuggets and I want to
see what this [__] guy is all about
that was shooting three-pointers I'm not
a big NBA guy as you know I've been
saying since the 2000s said it's [__]
massaged
right up to straight up fixed and uh you
won't be able to convince me otherwise
and you probably won't give a [__]
either oh here's another new thing sorry
my brain is all over the place here
um
I was talking to somebody about some
[__] on the phone
that you probably shouldn't talk about
on the phone you know if you don't want
people to start [__] listening or
things to perk up and I said I really
think to throw off
you know the guys in the van
is all you have to do at some point is
just say shape shifter
lizard people or Flat Earth and those
people all right this guy's just a jerk
off and I'll just keep moving on
laughs
so if you're ever talking about
something
you know I was talking about the Federal
Reserve or something like that like ah
you know we're getting a little too deep
with this and I just went Shape Shifter
lizard people
uh
yeah Flat Earth like all right that in
my head that gets them off the phone
call
if they're you know whatever the the
computer that's looking for the
buzzwords that it's like is this person
a danger yeah they just no one's
listening to this guy he thinks the
world is
and it's really as round as is bald head
all right that's it what about the
[__] devil race dude the Florida the
state of Florida is secretly [__]
quietly killing it
you know
I'm also type I'm tired of people saying
you know this [__] guy dude if he
played in New York or La you know
everybody would know his name it's like
well I don't understand why you don't
know his name if he scores [__] all
of these points he's gonna be on uh
ESPN right
no I don't [__] know anyway
all right
this has been the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday in the morning
podcast went a little longer a little
longer than usual
um
have a great weekend you [__]
congratulations to the Panthers and the
Denver Nuggets as I mentioned before and
I think it's going to be to hate I hate
to say it but
you never know
you never know things could happen
things
interesting things here we'll see okay
enjoy the music and then we have a bonus
half hour special the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast all right
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday
May 25th 2015
the final Monday
that there will ever be in May of 2015.
let me ask you
let me ask you what are you going to do
about it huh you ain't doing [__] today
are you I don't ever [__] word out of
anybody if this podcast if you consider
it late
is self-involved jackass if you consider
it late you got the day off anyways
don't you
well if you don't you either have a [__]
job or you work for yourself because
when you work for yourself [__] money
never sleeps or whatever dumb [__] they
say in some [__] hip-hop song you
know what I mean ain't how [__]
dramatic they try to make every goddamn
[__] moment you know
not all rappers but just in general
money never sleep More Money More
Problems not really
not if you would just move away
from the toxic element that you grew up
in
you know if you'd start buying some uh
uh some assets
if you had your money make money then
you don't have you don't have more
problems
stay out of the club
you have enough [__] money to to
bring some [__] over to your house
you don't wanna you don't need to go out
let me have a little [__]
old white guy to rapper discussion here
just [__] it once you make your money
get the [__] out of there
and don't listen to those [__] oh
yeah you forgot where you came from no
no
I remember where I came from
unless you don't see
I remember exactly where I came from all
right you want me to come back I'll come
back during the day when all you Maniacs
are still sleeping I'm not coming back
at night
Jesus Christ yeah you come back during
the day come back at like 10 in the
morning if you want to make a [__]
positive impact come back at 10 in the
morning
you know when the good people are
getting up right
you know watching their kids you know
he already went to work or whatever
that's the deal but that second shift
comes in that's when you get the [__]
out
that's what I would do I don't know
I mean that exists at all levels you
know what I mean
you're some [__] yeah just some
jackass from the suburbs you know what
you got to do you got to get out of you
got to get out of the town
whatever Town you're from where they're
still wearing the football jackets going
down to the water and hole right
dude how come you never come around
anymore what do you think you're [__]
too good for us
uh no I don't think I'm too good for you
I think I'm too good for this I'd like a
little more than this if you don't mind
that's all you got to do you just you
just [__]
you [__] have a bar in your house
that's what you do right
and then what you do is you invite your
friends over you have friends people you
know okay then if you want some [__]
or whatever you have them come over you
flip on the security camera so there's
no [__] he said she said right
you give the pimp a little [__] throw
Coat tea or whatever in his [__]
Sarsaparilla whatever [__] he wants to
drink you have a nice evening everybody
goes home
bang bang boom done you need to do all
of that in your Cabana you don't have
them in your real house
that's what you do
you know [__] go back down to the
sick goddamn what's wrong with you what
are you doing what am I talking about I
don't know I'm dishing out advice like I
have any business giving anybody advice
you know what I have a bar in my house
you know it's just a bunch of bottles
laying around you know I [__] you
know take a bite out of them every
[__] goddamn day you know what
I'm at my heaviest I've ever been
I've been talking to you guys singing
the gym Song and all that you know what
that southern tour
and then the 19 shows and then I got
sick and then I [__] kept eating like
an animal and I'm at my heaviest I've
been in [__] six years and I'll tell
you right now I'm disgusted with myself
Oh Billy fat again oh Billy red velvet
oh man what did I do
ah Jesus I gotta [__] you know what I
did everything I tell you guys not to do
I did and then
um I had a flight yesterday so I had to
do weight and balance so I had to get on
the [__] scale and I got on with my
clothes and it said 190. you know you
know I weighed myself this morning I was
186 with the [__]
shoes and cell phones and all that [__]
but uh
uh God I'm so disgusted with myself I
need to lose 15 [__] pounds 15
[__] pounds so what did I do I did
the usual all right [__] this
[__] this I'm getting in shape you know
when you do that and it [__] lasts
for about 12 hours
so I'm about 12 hours in
after I weighed myself I was so [__]
disgusted
he had a good lesson though and then uh
I came home
and I finished off this salad with
salmon and then for dinner I had a
[__]
black bean burger no bun with a side
salad
you know ugh crush me to order that and
but I gotta tell you after I ate it I
felt great
felt great and I drank Waters the rest
of the night and I figured all right
you know with clothes on and everything
on 190 so I'm probably about 185 186
eating like this I'll wake up in the
morning I'll probably be about 184 right
woke up in the morning 186.8
I'm a fat freckled [__] right now
I'm a [__] flounder I don't like it
ugh
I'm not even a button-down shape right
now you know that when you buttons get
too [__] they start having a [__]
you know that that stress mark on both
sides of the shirt is it's holding it
together I think you should do a joke
about that Mac where the button was like
an iron doing the Iron Cross trying to
hold both sides together it's [__]
horrible
it's absolutely horrible so
I don't know I ate my way into it I got
to eat my way out of it because I don't
really have time to [__] go too nuts
I did take my dog on a two-hour hike
today but um I don't know what an
[__] you know if you don't really
[__] me sent me I've been off the
rails on and off the rails since
November or October when I started uh
sat in the writer's room F is for family
and I started working eight hours a day
and we started ordering lunch and all
that type of [__] and I I felt myself
putting it on like five pounds then I
held the five pounds and then right into
the [__] holidays threw on another
three
and then somewhere I don't know in March
I started going back to the gym after I
was back I was up to like I was like 172
before this [__] started then I [__]
went up into the 180s again then I was
coming down to like 179 and then the
southern tour came out the other [__]
side of it
at 186 I mean I guess that's not bad I
gained six [__] seven pounds
ah
[__] worst every time I go to set up
I feel like I'm [__] got a kid
it's a kid growing in me a little fat
[__] kid
um
anyways so last night I stayed in for
the first night since I can even [__]
remember I didn't drink you know I
always have a couple of drinks I'm not
gonna lie to you there's no reason for
me not to I don't have any children all
right you'd be doing it too don't judge
me so last night I'm staying in you know
took my dog for a walk around the block
staring down in my stomach
[__] looking at myself in the mirror
going look at you fat shaming myself
look what you did
look at you
you're a [__] mess right awful
[__] awful right you know what's even
worse was I continued to [__] lift
weights as I put on all this weight so
now I look like that classic [__] uh
you know the only thing I'm missing is
is like you know what that guy that
keeps [__] working out
but he keeps eating like an [__] so
he's got the pecs in the shoulders and
he's just got that [__] awful gut
right and then he's got the tight button
down and you just see the [__] shirt
struggling every time the guy [__]
reaches over to grab another potato skin
that's the kind of [__] shape I'm in
right now
um
so anyway so I stayed in last night and
uh
I just watch TV you know which is always
good when you're trying to drop weight
whatever I didn't [__] drink go [__]
yourself so uh I watched that if you
watch that Rich Kids of Beverly Hills
it's [__] unbelie it's just one of
those things my wife
taped a bunch of [__] you know and for
some [__] reason you know she's
always telling me she doesn't delete my
[__] but whenever I come off the road
all my shows you know Fast and Loud
where's all the fast and louds
where's all hey Nia where's all the Fast
and Loud
you know I yelled that because I know
she's up and she's just like oh well I
didn't do anything really
it's not recording the series anymore
how does that happen if I hit record
series
and then I go on the road and I leave
what happened
are you gonna tell me it was a
malfunction
how come whenever it malfunctions the
the the the DV ah why does it always
malfunction on the [__] I want to record
you know I don't [__] know so anyways
so I'm like all right any port in a
storm
I watched the rest of that show The
Comedians one of my favorite new shows
that and last man on Earth of course
um
so great to see Billy Crystal again you
know such a big fan of this man he's
[__] hilarious on that show
and uh
I don't know if you guys have seen the
show I just love how
Josh gad's character has no idea all the
accomplishments
that Billy Crystal has uh has gotten
over the years it'll be like yeah you
know I'm up for a kid's choice of work
and can you believe that can you believe
it and he's like yeah I'm up for one too
he's like oh yeah yeah he goes yeah yeah
he goes I've won that I've won one of
those
he just really I I know I just love that
he has no [__] that's so such like
a sobering thing in this [__] I guess
in life in general is where you're going
to accomplish all this [__] you just
think you're gonna be the [__] man
and you just don't understand that
there's a whole generations of kids that
are coming up that could give a [__]
which is why
if you make money at some point you've
got to become a landlord
oh I'm on my way I'm on my way
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna [__] do it
I always said I was never gonna do it
but I'm gonna do it I was like I don't
want to be [__] dealing with fixing
toilets and [__] I'm not going to do
that I'll get someone to manage the
building for I'm gonna buy something I
gotta do it that's my exit strategy
right
instead of going out and buying a bunch
of shiny [__]
right going down to the club and getting
in trouble no
you stay at home
you drink yourself just shy of 200
pounds well you check out real estate
that's what you do so as you set
yourself up financially you
simultaneously destroy your hat and
liver
right and then you stick it all in a
will and you give it to your wife and
that one day right you're sitting there
having an egg salad sandwich you're down
at the track come on you sex how are you
it's the next thing you know you slumped
over the rail take a horse tail to the
face and it's [__] over that's it
it's over but you know what everybody in
your life is psyched he was really smart
with his money oh thank God thank God
God bless them you know he died doing
what he loved doing what he loved
screaming at the horses
with a .30 blood alcohol level
having a massive coronary
that's what he liked to do do you know
he had seven heart yet seven
I wasn't fixed I thought it was seven
you know all the old [__] who never
die
sitting there in the coffee shop just
chatting away chatting away right
burning calories running their [__]
yaps they live forever
that's what [__] kills me all these
broads going on TV [__] moaning and
complaining yeah we don't get this we
don't get that you [__] live forever
hey look who's here wow you look [__]
amazing
is it possible for you to do the podcast
and not scream at the top of your
[__] lungs is it possible for you to
do that
you're too good to be true can't take my
eyes screaming my name just a second ago
why were you screaming because I wanted
you to come up here you dummy I know but
you can do it in a little bit more of a
positive way and not call me a dummy as
well
and if it's quite all right pull up a
[__] chair
pull up a chair and grab a microphone
you [__] and I wanna I want you to
explain to me you're you you have
limited time on this podcast today why
because
[__] look at me like that all right
listen go get a [__] chair
why don't you have a chair in here this
office is a disgrace
you know it's a disgrace is my [__]
torso
186.8 Nia that's what you're banging huh
a big [__] flounder
I'm getting I'm getting I'm rapidly
approaching get on top get on top weight
oh God you still gonna love me Nia when
that brow sweat is raining down on you
like the [__] goddamn I don't know
something about the rainforest what a
[__] the microphone we put a cap on
both of our weights huh you look great
where the [__] is my uh there's a
there's another mic in in the in the
thing there
can't stop eating like a pig
he's a fat freckled [__] I [__] hate
myself right now Mia hate it good put
the put the windscreen on Jesus Christ
goddamn [__]
there we go here we go setting up the
microphone ladies and gentlemen coming
to the podcast
oh my god there you go how's this that's
very good now I want to know something
Neil yes
okay you're adorable you're beautiful
even when you snore it's cute as opposed
to me right right let me ask you this
how when I go on the road is Fast and
Loud
yeah the series screaming recording
we've made that point like nine times
I just want people to be clear that this
is just a thing that you do I rag I did
that I did that so I could have you come
up here all right and I gotta tell you
something else Leah this screaming that
I do that puts fruit loops on the table
oh my God I knew that's where you were
going with this why because of your
screaming that's right yeah yeah I got
it just check it in on you they love it
I know but we are not every time we are
not retired I am not an audience every
time you sit down I don't need you to be
screaming like your life they need a
nice save it for the stage sweetheart
save it for the [__] stage
[Laughter]
every time you sit down and eat a nice
crunchy cereal you got to say to
yourself thank God my husband screams
like a lunatic right
so what are you talking about fast and
loud I told you I don't know what
happened
okay don't Point your finger at me well
you're sitting there giving me [__]
about screaming and yelling last night
I'm trying to go to bed and you're
watching that Frankie Valli Musical yeah
yeah and I'm trying to sleep and every
every [__] five seconds you were
asleep though Sherry baby
you know what's funny is that you
already kind of have a higher pitch
voice so it's actually not hard for you
to go into that register that wasn't bad
listen don't compliment me because
you're watching your [__] TV
um
it was better on stage than it was in
the movie version it looked great oh
thank you meanie Ebert
who who in God's name would care what
you think about a [__] movie why do
you have me up here then if you're just
gonna be an [__] to me I'm so [__]
god what is wrong with this this is how
I say I love you I know why why did No
One Forever a seventh grade boy pulling
pigtails oh shut your face why why is
Fast and Loud not recorded
I have asked I I know you've asked me
nine times and I'm answering you nine
times I don't know I don't know why
really that's it I haven't erased
anything that's interesting and I take
games and I come back and the games you
know what happens is you're sitting here
and you're taping two things at once
right our DVR has the capability to tape
five things at once and I've never taped
five things at once so even if I did
have two things going on at once
I don't know Bill I don't know
is there anything worse than when you
think you're ever if you think you have
them
I thought we still had the old school
one well back in the day when we when
you recorded two things at once you used
to race my [__] all the time so I'm
yelling at you about that what did I use
surveys of yours all the time every
[__] game and you always go oh can
you get rid of some of this stuff from
the DVR it's all my stuff every Super
Bowl on the TV live we won it's never
coming up on the DVR like forever
do you need to have you don't even go
back and watch it what are you talking
about how do you how do you know what I
do
have you gone back and watched it yeah
I've watched that Super Bowl three times
and I loved it more each time we watched
it great Super Bowl against two great
teams and two great coaches I really
don't I love conversation about sports
with you although wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey hey easy you walked into my
restaurant not the other way around you
asked you okay what's on the menu what's
on the menu you don't like it [__]
take a hike lady do you know who you
like Justin James
number 99
from the uh yeah you don't have the
right name that sounds like a guy
Buffalo Bills wait Justin James he
sounds like he [__] builds hot rods
you're thinking Jesse James he's the one
he was on that wait I'm gonna look it up
he's the one I was just Justin
Timberlake no I was outside your element
I was just looking on an Instagram of
his because he was showing a picture
that's why you're so pretty he was um
he had this big scar on his um thigh or
something what's his name I don't know
Leah anyway oh Jesus so why did you have
me come up here because I was giving you
[__] about it fast and loud it's my
[__] show and I like seeing what they
do I know but I I don't know what
happened to it and you can also go
online because they have everything
online now I don't do that you don't do
that I oh I'm sorry is it was that not
you watching people slap fight each
other on YouTube yeah that's what like
an hour and a half I'm not gonna watch
it for for a quality piece of
entertainment someone wants to slap
somebody in the face and how funny was
that that that lady the big fat lady on
the on the uh the tricycle
[Music]
she was singing the R Kelly song and
then she [__] tips over in the end
it's [__] great
no it was a football player on the cover
of the [__] ESPN magazine who played in
the oh wait who did we play in the um
Seattle
okay
do you realize what you're doing to
listeners right now
um is that when Katy Perry was on did
the halftime show I'm sorry I know you
hate me right now
you gotta leave you gotta leave you're
done why because that was We're not
gonna answer questions no if that isn't
it that you know what come back during
that go go get yourself a [__] uh egg
McMuffin or something get me a water all
right get out of here out all right hold
on a minute well you're taking up time
here you're taking up time can you hear
this cereal
uh what guys this guy
I I don't know who that is
I don't know JJ Watts Oh Yeah from the
Texans all right
there you go yeah all right shut the
door I'll get me some water though come
back
Jesus Christ yes you're I'm a man I
asked you to do something you're a woman
you go and you do it you don't ask
questions
oh God so anyways like I was saying
they're sitting there [__] moaning and
complaining about all this stuff they
don't have but we
you know and it's like you [__]
outlive us you outlive us
what are you giving me water for in a
shot glass
come on Nia don't be a douche
well you know what you have a birthday
coming up I know exactly what I'm
getting you big bag of Fritos you're an
[__]
put it in the Juice Glass
all right so anyways yeah so they're
always [__] Mooring and complaining
about what they don't have right
you know do they ever look around and
see what they do have a whole [__]
platoona's shoes
huh that that guy paid for
right douchebag for a husband oh snap
12-6 right there baby
amen you know why I make more an hour
than you
because I'm better than you
because I'm worth more than you
think about it Nia think about all the
Great Inventions
think about all the great stuff that
makes your life simple as a broad
invented one of them as any of them stop
running their Yap for more than three
seconds to even invent the [__] can
opener
you know what that's actually a great
question let's go to broadinventions.org
see let's see what the ladies
women I gotta tell you something
inventors
okay I'm going to tell what would you
guys invent Skippy peanut butter
Marie Curie huh you know what your mic's
turned down for a reason
all right here we go women inventors
many years of your career yeah Mike's
back on
you've been squeezing this dumb premise
dry for the last 10 years of your career
move on to move on what are you having
for breakfast a nice big bowl of
feminism yeah well you know what that
that's [__] uh chauvinism paid for
that bowl of feminism famous women
inventors oh good are you actually gonna
learn something and not talk out of your
ass absolutely yeah this is going to be
a quick release be good it's gonna be a
quick read no it's not actually look at
all these people here it's like 12 names
you're gonna fall asleep before you get
there's more guys on the Clippers than
there's [__] women adventures Mary
Anderson Barbara Askins that takes care
of the A's
Patricia Billings Marion Donovan Sally
wet box
well what the [__] yeah do you think I'm
serious yes
let's see Mary Anderson anyone who's
ever driven in a rain or a snowstorm
really need to get a new bit though do
you really need to get a new bed what
are you talking about you know what I'm
talking about
what try I didn't trash women once my
last special you're
I didn't
but what's happening right now you still
come and wait you circling the wagon
back around to the same guy I have the
sniffles I don't feel good this is
comfort food for me oh this is
comforting to you oh you know what you
don't say discomfortable wait wait wait
so wait sad wait wait okay Miss
enlightened Miss enlightened what did
Mary Anderson invent I don't know oh
yeah claim to know what did Barbara
Askins invent I don't know the Post-it
how about Patricia Billings
I don't you call yourself a feminist and
you don't know your starting lineup you
want me to name the [__] Patriots
offensive line because I'll [__] do
it no I really Sally Fox do anything
regarding Sports uh yeah I don't know
what just because that doesn't mean that
I would know every female if that
doesn't make any sense but you don't you
don't know any of them
and I want you to tell me what one of
them did Dr Temple Grandin oh oh yes uh
she was the woman who invented the thing
for cows so when they were going to
slaughter they wouldn't be freaking out
like sort of like a little pressurized
thing that's on them because she had
like autism or something like that you
got some of it the thing that usually
amazes people about
most about prolific woman inventor Dr
Temple Grandin is not all the great
strides she has made to improve animal
handling devices you nailed it nor the
fact that she earned a PhD in animal
science
why is that amazing
you know what you are such a [__]
douchebag you can't give it up even when
it's in front of your face in black and
white like well I don't like how when
you guys I'm sick of you why wouldn't
you guys do [__] that we do it's
suddenly amazing you know what goodbye
you guys drove a garbage truck and
you're late garbage truck down the
street it'd be a lifetime movie over and
over and over again
premises that you've been doing for the
last 10 years
you know I like you come on you're being
a baby about this I'm not being a baby
you're being a neighbor I'm breaking my
balls you're getting all fresh down
there I uh I know who she is because
there was an HBO movie about it starring
oh there you go thank God knows you
can't sit down and read
all right really Bill what was the last
book you you read and [__] Stephen
Adler's biography doesn't count
I think that might have been the last
one
I read the uh fairy 2014 book
[Laughter]
whatever so you know so they you guys
you know you got a nice little list here
what I can't believe you felt the need
to go online as it to somehow wait did
women invent things like what is wrong
with you you I really had to keep asking
that question hey is it because you're a
46 year old white man from Boston like
is it can I really just distill it down
to your stats can I ask you a question
to you no you can't I want you to name
some women inventors Temple graded
I keep saying Marie Curie didn't she
invented yeah you're talking all this
[__] like I can't believe but you don't
even have the you don't even have the
bullets in your gun you're over there
you're shooting blanks I don't need to
have bullets I know you don't all you
got to do is start bitching and
everybody listens to you because I'm
smart enough
you're the one going online like a
prehistoric don't blow your nose into
the microphone Jesus how are you still
sick anyway
listen
because I'm up all night trying to find
something you guys did
[Music]
if anybody takes this [__] seriously
go [__] yourselves you know somebody's
gonna take a little clip of this and set
it to some Clambake [__] site and
I'll get in trouble
yeah whatever the [__] they are
Glam baby oh my god let's just focus
let's just focus on the neck Nia I swear
to God when I went to India and I saw
that toddler take a [__] between two
Park cars that [__] I don't know yeah
I don't hear people complaining
she's sitting there with a brooch you're
wearing a brooch that's more than that
kid will ever have what is your problem
what are you talking about bro I'm
talking all whenever those women get on
TV start complaining they start dressing
like [__] uh Eleanor Roosevelt don't
they put on a wool suit when's the last
time you saw anyone wear a brooch that
wasn't like I thought the people in
Canada were wearing them but it had to
do with World War One veterans I thought
that was abruption I got a bunch of [__]
about that you know but thank you
thankfully the Canadians are very
forgiving people you know you get them a
couple of donuts down to Timmy hoax and
they're fine
who do you like for the Stanley Cup Nia
um the Bruins oh geez we didn't make the
L.A Kings go Kings go neither one of
them you're all for two oh
those L.A Kings game we went to were fun
though they were I did enjoy it I was
very surprised at how enjoyable it was
we're glad we went there you go you know
now if I said the same thing about women
inventors I'd be a [__] chauvinist I
don't understand how me going to a
hockey game for the first time is like
you pretending to not humor it's called
humor oh okay it's called a joke
well thanks for explaining that Bill
thank God you're here to explain things
thank God a man is here to explain
things to a woman do without you what
are you trying to turn it around because
it's okay you didn't understand it it's
okay I didn't understand things
where are the questions for this week's
podcast uh I don't think we're up to
that point yet I don't even have the
advertising yet oh I was gonna say have
you read your advertising horribly yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
every time you make fun of me you're
just making fun of yourself why is that
because you married me you dope
I married you because I love you
be nice to me in the podcast all right
all right that's it
okay can you give me some [__] water
in a real glass or a real glass okay I
know minimal [__] effort you probably
want the same amount an hour for this
right that a busboy would do and he'd
bring me a [__] bus boy would bring
over a full glass like a man
yeah
all right sweet cakes
all right there we go Jesus Christ
anyways
Nia you outlive us
um all right
oh by the way I'm I'm performing down at
The Comedy Store ladies I'll be down
it's
not [__] long enough
oh you wanted a regular yeah I wanted a
regular glass no what's the matter do
you start thinking about dresses on the
way to the kitchen
I'm being an extra douche this week but
you know what I'm enjoying it all right
um
I want to be down the customer hosting
in the uh the main room at 8 30 this
Wednesday there's only a few tickets
left and you yes you could be one of the
lucky people to come down and watch the
uh more to loves Bill Burr take the
[__] stage
at The Comedy Store on 8 30. it's an all
things comedy show and uh it's a
Powerhouse lineup and all of that type
of stuff and I got a bunch of new bits
that I'm really excited about doing and
um
you know who's on the show huh oh I
don't know [__] Neil Brennan Al
Madrigal bunch of bunch of beasts you
know what do you want from me what do
you want from India
I want you to address the issues yeah
important in society
the ones that affect me [__] everybody
else
um all right where the hell are we
trying to see what the [__] I would have
I don't even know how to do this Twitter
thing I'm trying to see where the hell I
am
my thing uh gives a [__] anyways yeah I
don't know who the [__] on the show
it's going to be a great show but come
on down how was that was that good also
people have been asking me hey Bill I
really like some of those posters you've
had on your recent tours are there any
leftovers why yes yes there are the
first batch of leftovers at least things
will go fast I hope
um I have uh some posters left over from
my Southern tour uh the Billy Bible Belt
tour and uh they're all autographed
and uh they make a great gift for
somebody you don't really give a [__]
about all my [__] does you know because
it's always 20 bucks say you got 20
bucks go [__] yourself frame it make a
[__] night of it just get out of my
house
um those will go on sale on Wednesday
um
and then the Boston ones will be coming
on sale I think uh whenever the [__] I
get those back I got about 100 or so of
those left
so anyways there we go I don't have any
goddamn
I don't have any reads for this week
this is a very Lo whatever everybody's
got the day off right why do I have to
try this week
all right I just got myself in all kinds
of trouble hey needy come here
come in here come in here lady
oh
all right well I guess I'm gonna have to
do a uh oh so how about that [__]
Ducks Blackhawk series that's incredible
huh
I was really I was really psyched that
the Blackhawks won game two I mean game
make it 2-2 sorry game four only because
I want to see that thing go seven games
because uh it's just hockey at the
highest level
and um
what is that
what happened I was looking at his other
leg
oh we're back to to uh
JJ Watts yeah
yeah what happened
that's a bruise yeah from what getting
hit
I think he got hit dude his legs look
like he's 80.
anyways yeah am I here okay Hey listen
obviously I think a woman should make
what a guy makes okay but you guys need
to let your [__] hair down and let a
guy say some dumb [__] every once in a
while without getting all [__] you
know I don't employ anybody [__]
relax
I can't wait for you guys to make as
much as we make maybe once you're going
to a bar and maybe throw down a [__]
C note and buy a round
how do you know I haven't bought around
drinks for somebody because I've known
you for 10 years
they're buying me a drink yeah after all
I do for you is is a [__] joke okay
you're throwing a nickel into an ocean
here all right what else do I do for you
I'm talking about that's not when when
have you ever just walked into a [__]
bar slam down a [__] C note and just
bought a round of drinks for people
because you're having a great [__]
day have you ever done it no I don't
even I don't even know have you ever
done that yeah and throw down a C note
just because you were having a great
[__] day hey drinks on me
like that like I got one fully done that
I went to a speakeasy which is never a
speakeasy because it's legal but they
had its design in when we were in uh
in Denver me and Jason lawhead we go in
there we're going to go to the Broncos
uh
so it was like the first game in the NFL
season
might be weird don't be there when they
won the Super Bowl anyway oh because it
was against the Steelers at the end one
I can't [__] remember whatever we
went to the bar so we go to the bar and
um oh shut up so we go to the bar and
they had uh they had this
ins I don't know what the [__] it was
but it was like 60 years old okay all
right it was I don't know what it was
whatever you can have everything else
turns to like [__] vinegar what was
it a Kanye what couldn't be like 60
years old
I don't know I don't know so whatever it
was like [__] like 90 bucks a shot
so I just had a great run of dates and I
said [__] it I said lawhead
I said we're doing this he goes dude you
can't do that I go [__] that come on
first game of NFL season who gives a
[__] government's taking on my money
anyways let's do that right so the
bartender I see it he goes oh my God
he's like that's like the greatest I
mean people at the bar bartenders we
always he's a young kid we want to do
this shot and I said all right I go I'm
buying you a shot too
he goes no no no I can't do that I can't
do that and whatever his name was I was
like Doug yes you can so then he said
all right he goes this is the thing can
I split the shot with two of the other
bar backs I said yeah there you go
there's my hundred bucks I threw it down
we all we all took a sip and it was one
of the great experiences I've ever had
drinking anything in my [__] life so
there you go congratulations
damn
you know what that was classic right
there female [__] well you just said did
you ever do it I gave you a [__]
example and then rather than saying like
oh I stand corrected you then say I
stand corrected you're right you went in
you threw it down you gave everybody a
good time yeah great do you think that's
an isolated incident
I don't know there was no it wasn't oh
well the amount of money that could be
in our bank the amount of money that
could be in our bank account but isn't
because I'm such a great [__] guy
it's ridiculous well I'm glad everyone
is getting to see what a great guy you
are and they're not completely basing
and understand
laughs
this is what happens when you marry a
smarty even when you get them they
[__] wiggle their way out of it all
right
let's read some questions all right
let's get some questions before you go
to your [__] uh
Sally Field meeting
you gonna go to a meeting this week is
that a normal rate reference yeah hold
up a Union sign
she made a sign it was so amazing come
to Brazil
hey Bill hey man I know hey man I don't
exactly know how it works but I think
you're a really talented and hilarious
comic well it's nice to know someone in
this [__] side of the world does my
friends and I have seen most of your
shows available online and we love it I
believe you have a real Market
opportunity in Brazil have you ever
considered coming here anyways keep up
the good work
uh car in La question mark hello
that's the next one oh that's the next
one no sorry I thought that was him
signing off
um I'm so dumb
yeah I mean I would go to Brazil
yeah
I didn't say I was taking you
there you go huh no you go you you go
you you go
you go to Brazil you deserve it you're
so [__] you know
thank you abused in this country you
poor women I mean Jesus Christ I mean
all the stuff that we do to you
it's just got it's got to be horrible
living in your four bedroom Garrison
Colonials having the list how do you do
it how do you American women do it how
do you [__] handle it well I'll tell
you Bill it's not devastating it's not
easy Bed Bath and Beyond every [__]
20 feet Bed Bath and Beyond yeah really
oh come on dude that's your Buffalo Wild
Wings you know what it is you guys love
going in there buying [__] I also like
Buffalo Wild Wings
I know you do you like anything that
costs money
oh all right
they just look this is how it happens
Nia this is how it happens
and then somebody else says yeah I'll go
you know I'll go down there for another
grand priest
they have a Grand Prix there I don't
know what about Carnival
I'm not gonna go down there watching
Everybody shaking their asses oh really
because you would have just such a hard
time watching a bunch of hot Brazilian
women exactly naked shaking their asses
I would have a hard time I'd have a very
hard time I'd be standing like Ron
Burgundy with my [__] slacks erection
I would
oh [__] you Nia all right car in La
hello Billy biceps no I never got into
that whole [__] thing going into some
[__]
you know dude go to Amsterdam you can
walk into this [__] [__] in the
window well I I don't think Carnival is
like that it's just it's like everyone's
like dancing and celebrating yeah
walking around with their asses hanging
up it's not like going into the red
light district in Amsterdam though as
far as I could tell Brazil is is like
what's what's like your Capital there
Rio is it real though I have no idea I
don't know apart from what I've heard
from my friends it's one big red light
district but I guess that that's just
where they went oh that's because your
friends were animals and they just went
there for the we know what that's that's
something different they went there to
expect you know experience the culture
the legalities that are afforded too
women who aren't allowed to how much fun
was this podcast before you got here all
right all right Billy biceps really
really [__] grandmother arms now that
I've kissed your ass a bit make sure you
work on those triceps those are the real
beach muscles like I go to the beach I
got a question uh to throw your way good
Lord dude that's what I figured you know
get to it I have been working in the TV
industry and I'm loving it I have
applied for a gig out there in LA and
wouldn't mind hearing a rant about what
it is like to live out there I love
biking everywhere the one with the
pedals and everyone tells me that I move
that if I move out there I will need a
car
uh [__] but for real what are your
thoughts I like electric I like electric
cars is that practical thanks
for an average podcast at best go [__]
yourself oh Jesus this guy all right
hang on a second I evidently I can't
blow my nose on the mic
yeah
oh yeah got all of that one gross
um you know what Nia you think he can do
better huh you think you could find a
better balding fat freckled redhead you
go out you go do it I don't know why you
keep saying that you know you [__]
see this look at that I think you look
great
you know something here
you're not helping me classic comedian
response no you're not helping me I
don't want to take a compliment I don't
look great [__] right now rather stay in
the self-loathing space [__] if you
don't look good I don't tell you you
look good
you know okay
if you noticed in 2009 I didn't say a
[__] thing to you
all right uh yeah you can bike
everywhere but it's really dangerous
there's a lot of frosted bicycles out
here
um and now there's this weird thing
where they just drew a bicycle in the
middle of the street
and all the people on bikes go see
that's a bike lane it isn't what it is
is you get money from the federal
government if you just spray paint a
bike on a street is that true yeah
that's why they do it because it doesn't
really feel like it's always a proper
lane it's just like a little section off
to this it's not a lake they put it they
put it like a third of the way out into
the road and then these people on
bicycles are like I have a right to be
out there and it's like of course you do
absolutely but when there's a car behind
you just get over to the right let us
get past there's such [__] [__]
they go out there and they dress like
they're in a bike race and they won't
get the [__] out of the way so don't be
one of those guys and then what happens
is if they get hit it's a [__]
tragedy it's like no you're a [__]
who's riding a bicycle
like I stopped riding a motorcycle out
here it was insane to be on a motorcycle
and I'm going as fast as [__] cars
now you're going to be out there on a
bicycle which is basically a motorcycle
without a motor
right yeah you're out of your mind you
can definitely bike out here people bike
all the New York City again New York
City is incredible maybe don't rely on
your biking to and from work and stuff
when you come out here just now what you
have to do is you got to go down side
streets you got you gotta you got to
figure out a way to Serpentine but I
would not drive go down sunset or Santa
Monica or Melrose Beverly all the main
ones Highland La Brea
uh kawanga uh Fairfax all right Crescent
Heights La Cienega
Doheny tell them how wonderful it is to
live out here Third Avenue Wilshire
Third Street Third Street there you go
on Third Avenue I'm talking about Santa
Monica
third straight no those are Avenues out
there Third Street like Third Street
Promenade Third Street Promenade yeah
not Third Avenue but then down down the
way here is Third Avenue okay it isn't I
don't know just talk to him about how
great this is about here that's great uh
we're running out of water there's uh
baby seals washing up onto the shore
because the oceans are fished out it did
kind of rain today I think maybe got
real cloudy very overcast it's like
overcast it's yesterday
I'm gonna see ex machina today what is
that
Mad Max one of the other or both both
movies star and women God knows you guys
will complain or something yeah but the
trailer when you if you had a penis it'd
be bigger
um I just like breaking your [__]
balls because everybody just sits there
going oh my God everything you say is so
valid did you talk to him about the
electric car because I know you've been
wanting to getting a life oh you like
your car
it's super expensive though no
um I don't know we
uh super expensive no
um well there's two testers there's like
the the S-Type that has uh one electric
motor and that's
uh moves the rear wheels like the old
days and then they have the new one I
forget what it's called but that has two
Motors
one for the front and one for the back
and what's amazing about electric power
from what I've I've been looking is that
um
the torque is instantaneous
you know however you say it like 691
pounds of torque and zero RPMs like
immediately I think that's why I can't
have a transmission because it would rip
the [__] gears right out of it but
then I don't understand how I don't I've
never seen the inner workings of it so
how does it turn the wheels and not
[__]
you know rip those things to shreds when
I was looking on the website they have
all these diagrams and videos and stuff
oh I gotta I gotta look at it it's it's
amazing and you can at this point you
can drive across the country with the
one that has two Motors because you're
gonna drive it like a maniac yeah get
like 150 miles before you got a uh
you know recharge it and then the S1 you
get like 200 something or whatever but
all I know is you know the average
person you know you're not going on a
[__] road trip I mean 150 miles for a
lot of people is like three four days of
work you come home every day you charge
it like a cell phone and then you never
have to go to a gas station again and
right now the Golden Age of electric
cars the the recharging is free you know
eventually that's not going to be free
the only issue I had though when I was
looking at the website they have a map
because you can put in your um zip code
and it'll tell you where all the charge
stations are and like they're all at
hotels
and it's like they're for hotel guests
only like there's one no if you get the
car you'll have one at your house too
oh right well that makes sense yeah they
should see the people down the street
with their thing plugged in and they
have them at the mall like all the malls
and everything like that they've got
them everywhere so I don't think it's
impractical no not at all so evidently
they're popping up like uh
and multiplying
um but everybody I know that has one
everybody that doesn't have one is
nervous about getting one like oh my God
what if it just shuts off
but everybody know that has one says
they [__] ear to ear grin who has one
that you know
I want to ride in one I want to see what
it's like uh bunny mind that plays drums
has one another bunny minded comedian
has one okay I'm not gonna save it I'll
tell you afterwards but okay um I've
driven one it was I just draw the one
that has the motor in the back it was
the fastest [__] car I ever drove it
was sick that's cool you just step on it
and it's just into the seat
flying it's amazing um the only thing
the only thing I didn't like though is
the center console like on the dashboard
it's like this it's this huge yeah super
sized iPad it's very I feel like it
would be really distracting I would want
to shade
to pull down over and it's like you can
go online it's like but why do you why
do you need to be doing that I don't
want to be driving if anything you use
it for like the radio and well they're
constantly sending you up like you get
in the car and then they'll just beam
you updates yeah that's distracting
that's not no no no you get there and
it's just updated like oh this is cool
oh okay do you know they have a thing
where the new uh you know all the new
cars the suspension like the Corvettes
and stuff you can have like you know
regular suspension
Sports suspension Super Sport whatever
[__] you want to call they have a sports
suspension and then their next one is
just called insane
that's kind of stupid but actually kind
of like it
um all right where am I going here
Jesus did you watch any of the Cavaliers
game
you know that I didn't oh my God
everybody in the Cavaliers limping
around like they're playing soccer
making all these faces and [__] I don't
understand you barely step on a guy's
toe and you see a mountain of a man just
crumpled to his knees
and then he wins the game and then
LeBron immediately is like oh a camera's
on me let me crumple down to the floor
and then he said this [__] where they go
uh you know how was the game whatever he
goes he's like well if I'm gonna be a
leader of this team even if I'm hurt I
need to step up it's like are you
writing what they're supposed to be
saying he is really interesting Sports
Center he's really good at media he
really isn't that's how he got in
trouble the first time I'm taking my
talents to South Beach but these kids
today they all grew up on [__] nice
kids today yeah they all grew up on
Sports in it so they speak in sound
bites and then the [__] the animals
on sports centers just repeat them so
back in the day nobody ever [__] said
[__] like that Moses Malone you [__]
had 90 rebounds and 50 points uh how'd
you do that he's like I just goes to the
wreck
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
Larry you guys lost by 20. what happened
yeah we played like a bunch of sissies
that was it I was joking about that with
law ahead if he said that today he'd
have to [__] go to uh stuff calling
people sissies.net and apologize
what is your comments on Larry Bird's
hateful statements um
all right so uh yeah I would get elected
as much as there's the Chevy Volt
there's a bunch of things if you want to
get something like that
um
but I think you'll really get into cars
out here because you're living them um
speaking of which I get my truck back
tomorrow so what was going on was the uh
there was a spring on the clutch that
was touching the exhaust so that was the
only problem thank God so there's
nothing wrong with the clutch anything
in the transmission all right
oh I might yeah at any point if you want
to [__] walk out you [__] all
right baseball season bill is it me or
is baseball in a rut there's nothing
exciting going on no great pitching
performances no exceptional bats did you
check out any Sox games when you were
back in Boston
um I can address all of that you
probably came of age during the steroid
era um I'm actually loving it I think
baseball is back to the way it should be
I love that Casey boring it was uh you
don't like any sports I I feel like
baseball is especially
I don't know it just can be it doesn't
yeah it doesn't appeal to you it's not
like I guess I don't know is that lame
though I mean is baseball really an
amazing sport I'm not giving it enough
of a chance because I feel like
basketball games I like to go to hockey
games maybe because it's just constantly
fast-paced there's yeah there's always
actions and play yeah okay maybe that's
it yeah you got to settle into uh
you got to settle into baseball and once
you understand a little more what's
going on it's like Cricket I thought
cricket was the dumbest thing I ever saw
and then when I started learning some of
the rules it's actually really kind of
cool oh okay so whatever if it's you
know some sports just aren't for you
like for the life of me I sat down and
after everything was done
remember you came home last night you're
like why are you watching the Rich Kids
of Beverly Hills yeah it was because the
basketball was done the baseball was
done the hockey was done and I put on
some soccer or whatever football and uh
I tried watching it of course I put it
on and there's some guy laying on the
ground crying
and everybody's sitting there and all
you know flapping their arms around like
the biggest tragedy just [__]
happened and I just just bores me to
tears I love MMA that's like my favorite
sport at the moment okay I like that too
all right so whatever okay um also I
want to say that despite you getting
[__] for sticking up for Brady you
always really you're always really kind
to most teams when they win you can
graduate teams that beat your teams I
don't know why you get so much [__] are
you allowed to hate the Canadians in
Alabama or whichever team
it is down there you trashed uh thanks
for get uh for the laughs oh I'm glad
somebody [__] noticed like I didn't
trash the Canadians too much for [__]
losing how could I we didn't even make
the playoffs
um
but uh I gotta tell you that Tom Brady
suspension is a [__] tragedy
oh and all the people that spoke up John
Elway go you know you got to follow the
rules really John Elway like when you
get drafted you [__] show up
he didn't the guy gets drafted and he
goes oh I'm not gonna play with the
Colts the Colts suck trade me John
that's not how it works well [__] you
then I'm gonna go play baseball all
right John
that guy came in Breaking [__] rules
and he's gonna turn around and say that
[__] half God [__] all of these [__]
people it's ridiculous [__] NFL
doesn't even pay taxes for goddamn 70
[__] years
you're a non-profit oh my God the
[__] horseshit
four games near the guy who dropped he
punched a woman in the head got [__]
two games
until the video got out and they're like
oh wait a minute we mean we don't
tolerate that here all right worst
pickup line ever
worse well that one that one you respond
to right
because that involved the lady God
you're selfish uh worst pickup line ever
Bill heard you talking about bad pickup
lines me and my friends do this all the
time one night we were trying to think
of the worst pickup lines to open up
with to a girl with dude that's some of
the funnest nights you ever have it's
just saying the worst [__] just watching
you guys it's fun for you guys yeah it's
not about you then why are you saying it
it is you just say it to each other then
listen Nia if you [__] told me you're
trying to involve us in your [__]
dumb you're dumb that's gonna come up
with the words pick up lines ever
that'll be hilarious like why don't you
just you know do it for each other why
do you have to bring us into it yeah
if you did that something like that to
guys with your lady friends there I
would think it was funny if you just
started [__] with guys it'd be funny
I I don't know maybe
yeah
I don't know I haven't tried to throw
out lines to anybody in a bar in 11
years so maybe I'm a little out of
practice
worst pickup line ever all right blah
blah blah sorry Nia you want to leave on
this one because it's so [__]
annoying all right what night we're I'm
already annoyed by the question I don't
even know what it is but go on one night
we're trying he said he he sent this on
his cell phone we were trying to think
of the worst pickup lines to open up to
a girl and trying to be as creepy as
possible stumbled onto approaching a
girl and opening up with the line of so
how old were you when you got your
period oh Jesus Christ
why
you sound like a [__] pedophile you
know why so how old were you when you
got your period what I can explain it in
one no I don't even explain it two words
now
Apocalypse Now the horror
[Music]
what is the what is this what is the
rest of this jackass say this is like
this is like a 20 year I hope to God
this is like a 20 year old person and
not a man in his 30s that knows better I
don't know who this is but I love him
because he's [__] annoying you all
right this is as a this did this as a
goof with four different strange woman
oh after I said it to a few of the girls
I knew first as a joke of course and
something surprising happened they
started telling me about it
unfazed by the creepy inquiry it's
almost like they've been waiting to talk
about it forever oh yeah we are just
waiting forever to talk to some strange
[__] in a bar about the first time we
got our period are you [__] insane
and who are you talking to drunk
sorority [__] they don't count
sorry okay
you're yelling at this man's just
sharing his experience sorry ha ha he
says yeah exactly I'm not saying you
should actually use this as a pickup
line but I will I really thought you
were seriously suggesting this oh you
gotta go in here but I will say that it
opened up a long conversation with four
different girls I didn't know and even
became friends with one of them I don't
know what that means but it seems pretty
surprising to me that they weren't
completely creeped out I figured they'd
be creeped out or leave or call the cops
or something anything but what actually
happened uh story qualifiers this line
was delivered in a joking yet
interesting tone interested tone and
these were some presumably trashy girls
at one of the trashiest bars in America
parentheses from Indianapolis
so don't try it on a girl at a bar at
the Plaza Hotel this is more of a Motel
6 bar Spooner so he basically they had a
sort of like confirm my point which
which is like you know what he did
say this dude
you know what he did I would be like oh
my God actually I was [__] 14 right
and I thought I was like so all and it's
like I felt really bad about myself but
then like my mom are you done that is
totally normal and it's like I can't
believe you're even asked me this
because most guys
can we make out what yeah dummies do you
know what he did near because any grown
woman
all right with half a goddamn [__]
brain cell even if you were like so no
but seriously when did you get your
period well look at you like the [__]
immature and jackass mourn that you are
and walk away from your ass you know the
fact that I'm even wasting my breath on
answering this ridiculous thing just
goes to show you shut up
all this guy did was he went out and he
had a little bit of fun well isn't that
just sweet boys just being boys a little
a little rap scallion is it oh get out
of here you Scamp is it okay for us for
boys to be boys
is it okay for us to do that or do you
have a problem with that no no not at
all is there a problem when girls be
girls what happens to you guys something
horrible that we need to understand
apparently men asked this when was the
first time that we had our uh period
okay you know something so anyway but
let me ask then you overstate your
welcome now
today I don't anymore so what did he
learn in all of this okay so fine all
right I'll relax I'll relax he was just
being silly and trying to be creepy and
trying to have a good time fine but like
so these women I'm sorry everybody their
period but what did they actually say
sorry how come I didn't did you actually
learn anything about a woman's menstrual
cycle
oh will you shut up like they're
supposed to learn something he's just
[__] around how did he even write it
write it in then I'm just trying to
understand the point because this is the
point the point is is we go out and we
have to try to [__] convince you guys
to have sex with us it's up to us to
[__] come up with some sort of line
and it's a [__] time was that his way
of like trying to get somebody to have
sex with him no what I'm saying is Nia
when you're [__] coming out and your
voice is changing and it's up to you to
initiate the thing it can be for a lot
of guys it's a very intimidating thing
so to get to the point in basically not
giving a [__] this is like a stand-up
comic who's no longer afraid of the
crowd and can handle himself and
actually can dig a little bit of a hole
no pun intended and maybe still be in
the [__] game all right that's all
he's doing here he's having a good
[__] time okay that's it and he went
into some [__] [__] thing and
he's having fun do you think he actually
hooked up with these pigs maybe he did
okay but if he did it's his dick in her
[__] vagina so stay out of it
golly why I understand what the [__] are
you just having a little bit of fun here
no I listen you just made a lot of good
points I know so you don't gotta go all
Edith Warden every [__] time a guy
puts a smile on his face
Edith Wharton is that lady who made the
flag and the Afghan in the late 1800s
now she was married she didn't like to
be [__] married we had to read the
stupid ass [__] book in college and
you know what it stunk
she was a feature-act at best
all right Dollar Shave Club
now you brought up a lot of good points
and I I I I rescind my ire in the last
one okay there you go if that means
you're gonna shut up I'm all for it oh
that's exactly what it means dollar
shaved Club everybody you've heard me
talking about dollarshaveclub.com the
company that delivers amazing raises for
a few bucks I know a razor that cost a
few bucks delivering a great shave seems
too good to be true right but you really
have to try the razors the
dollarshaveclub.com razors will give you
the most amazing shaves you've had in
years all right hey don't pay triple the
price when you can get a fantastic shave
delivered for just a couple of dollars
you'd have to be an idiot to keep
overpaying if that's what you want to do
God bless you all right don't be fooled
by the price these razors are legit and
you will never go back plus they've also
got Dr covey's easy shape butter
um it's phenomenal if you're still using
old-fashioned shave foam you know what
you're a loser and I feel bad for you
try dollarshaveclub.com bird today to
get started you wish you had done it
sooner that's dollarshaveclub.com what
is it Nia dollarshave.com no
dollarshaveclub.com sorry you fail
um LegalZoom
are you the world's next world famous
entrepreneur well neither am I that
doesn't stop you from using LegalZoom or
maybe you just don't care about Fame you
just want to help people whatever your
motivation if you're an innovator it's
easy to launch your dream this month
with legalzoom.com
um incorporate or form an LLC to start
your business register your trademark to
protect your products and services apply
for a patent to secure your invention
like all those wonderful women that
invented all that stuff over the past
decade LegalZoom has helped more than a
million people just like you turn their
ideas into reality so excuse me what's
special about this month for a time for
a limited time you can get a special
savings on any trademark copyright or
provisional patent application go to
legalzoom.com today to get started uh
they can even help you if you have a
great idea but you're not sure where to
begin since they're not a law firm you
can get advice from legalzoom's network
of independent attorneys in Most states
that means you can get the guidance you
need to get your great idea off the
ground don't forget to enter verb you
are in the referral box at checkout this
month for your special discount
legalzoom.com promo code Burr uh legal
help is here all righty there we go
Jesus Christ that played something is
going to hit the [__] house well the
I hope you enjoyed your time
this week on the podcast it's been a
long time yeah brow beating what are you
talking about you owned it last Thursday
for like a second this is the longest
I've been on and on guys is it ever
enough all right listen thank you I was
just saying I was like I'm [__] with
you I'm [__] with you
uh all right that's the podcast for this
week thank you for everybody for
listening uh once again I will be down
in The Comedy Store this Wednesday at 8
30 hosting the all things comedy uh
Network
uh live stand-up show with a bunch of
other comedians Neil Brennan Al Madrigal
go to uh the [__] comedy stores
website sorry
they'll figure it out and figure out
what's going on that's the podcast
uh my next big tour
why don't I give you that
I don't have a name for this one I'm
sorry to everybody but it's going to be
a West Coast tour uh [__] West Coast
tour
just sit right back in the air that
Tails uh it's going to start off in
Portland Oregon
and uh then I go what is Oregon like
uh you know I hear it's beautiful not
you wouldn't like it
um
I'm going
I've always wanted to go to to Oregon is
it in Portland though yeah yeah I want
to go to Portland it's supposed to be
really beautiful Oregon is not in
Portland Portland is in Oregon oh is
that what you said that's what I mean
Portland's not a state that's what I
meant neither is Seattle
Chicago state or city
what Chicago is that a state or a city
it's a state no it's a city wow oh my
God oh my God what I know
I was saying that to be insulting
Nashville
state or city city it's because you
watch the show that's true love that
show
what's the capital of Buffalo
the capital of Buffalo do you mean the
capital of New York
I don't know do I what is it it's um it
begins with an a
the capital of New York wait it's um oh
my God oh my God you only lived there
for 10 years
yeah look at this you want to make the
same amount of hours be unbelievable
what is the capital of New York I really
can't think of it right now my mind is
completely drawing a blank Albany yes
why not take Albany why did you say the
capital of Buffalo did you [__] up until
though no I was trying to trip you up oh
okay oh wait so look at your you're
going to be in Portland Oregon Capital
Buffalo it's going to be in Reno Nevada
June 20th Santa Rosa California June 9th
and 19th I'll be in uh Sacramento for
some reason okay uh June 21st Santa Rosa
June 22nd San Jose June 23rd Fresno
never been to Fresno June 24th
Bakersfield California June 25th
Highland California where is that is
that obviously New York it's uh in the
Inland Empire oh the IE [__] okay at
the same uh Manuel Indian Bingo and
Casino and yes June 26th and 27th Vegas
baby yay at the Mirage yeah I'm very
excited okay Tucson Arizona June 28th
and then he's in moyale on July 22nd and
July 23rd there you go for the Just for
Laughs Comedy Festival that's right and
I'm working on a Toronto date in uh
in September and then I'm also trying to
put together a bus run
yeah run it through six with my woes
do you know what I'm referencing of
course not
[__] holy [__] all right listen